شكرا لك يا ميسون بطبيعه الحال نتابع معكم
على شاشه العربيه تغطيه هذا الهجوم الذي
بدا قبل نصف ساعه حيث اعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدايه غارات على قطاع غزه
استهدفت عدد من المواقع داخل قطاع غزه
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور التي
تاتينا الان على الهواء مباشره مراسل
العربيه قال اعتراض صاروخ جنوب عسقلان
بواسطه القبه الحديديه هذه الصور قبل قليل
وردت الينا وسنتابع معكم لحظه بلحظه كل
تفاصيل هذا الهجوم الذي بدا قبل نصف ساعه
من الان حيث اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بدايه
غاره على قطاع غزه مراسل العربيه تحدث عن
ان الطائرات اسرائيليه كانت تحلق قبل قليل
فوق الحدود مع لبنان وكذلك ايضا مراسل
العربيه تحدث ايضا عن ان الفصائل
الفلسطينيه تطلق مضادات ارضيه تجاه
المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث عن ان
قواته الان تشن غارات على قطاع غزه طبعا
يعني هذا التصعيد كان متوقعا بالنظر الى
سيناريو الاحداث الذي بدا قبل ايام منذ ان
دخلت القوات الاسرائيليه باحات المسجد
الاقصى المسجد القبلي تحديدا وقامت باخلاء
المصلين بالقوه والمعتكفين في هذا المسجد
كما انها في ذلك التوقيت اطلقت الغاز
الموسيل للدموع وايضا اطلقت
الرصاص المطاطي دعونا نتابع معكم تفاصيل
ما يجري الان في قطاع غزه معنا مدير مكتب
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك
ضعنا في صوره ما يجري الان حسب اخر
المعلومات التي وردت اليك زياد
نعم لما يحدث هذه الغارات واسعه النطاق
تتركز حاليا حول مواقع
اساسا عسكريه وفق الدعاء الجيش الاسرائيلي
قال انه استهدف مسارات انفاق هجوميه يقال
هجوميه يعني انها تصل الى الحدود وقد
تجتاز الحدود بالاضافه الى مخازن وفق
البيان الاسرائيلي
لتصنيع الاسلحه تابعه
لحماس الان هناك اطلاق سفارات في مستوطنات
غلاف غزه وفي سبيروس تجاره اعتراض صاروخ
على الاقل مضادات ارضيه اطلقت بكثافه تجاه
المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
المغيره فتحت جميع الملاجئ في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من حدود قطاع غزه وحتى على بعد
40 كيلومترا من القطاع كل الملاجئ
المفتوحه الان تحسبا لا المكثف للطوارئ
لصواريخ اتجاه تلك المناطق عمليا هذا
الامر كما اسلف قبل
قليل ان اسرائيل تفضل ان يكون تكون
المواجهه مع قطاع غزه وليس مع حزب الله في
جنوب لبنان رغم ان الاجتماع الكلمه لم
ينتهي بعد فيما يتعلق ايضا بالرد حول
الاطلاق الثوريه من جنوب لبنان وان اتهمت
اسرائيل حماس مسبقا في الموضوع نعم طيب
يعني زياد يعني نحن نتابع معك هذه المشاهد
وهذه الصور بطبيعه الحال
المخاوف تزداد من تكرار السيناريو الذي
حدث قبل عامين ربما الان تتوفر ذات الظروف
يعني كنا في شهر رمضان قبل عامين حدثت تلك
المواجهات العنيفه في قطاع غزه هل يعني
تبدو اي مؤشرات لان تتكرر ذات الصور وذات
المشاهد حتى الان على الاقل
هذا الذي يحدث الان يذكر كثيرا بالبدايه
وهو قد يكون اعنف قصه اسرائيلي منذ سنوات
على هذه المشاكل كثافه الاطلاق الصواريخيه
كثافه كبيره جدا في كل موقع يطلق عشره
صواريخ او 20 صاروخا ببعض
الاحيان الان هناك اعتراض اضافي من
بطاريات القبه الحديديه لصواريخ تطلق من
قطاع غزه بينما نتحدث بهذا المعنى نعم
يمكن
للتذكير قبل عامين كان سبب شبه المباشر هو
اقتحامات الشيخ جراح والمسجد الاقصى من
قبل بن جزيره عندما كان نائبا في الكنيسه
الاسرائيلي اليوم هو وزير في الحكومه وعضو
في الكبد
الانمي ايضا
الامور قد تتصاعد في قطاع غزه هذه الليله
كان واضحا منذ الان
بغض النظر عن اطلاق الصواريخ اليوم من
جنوب لبنان اتجاه الجليل كان واضحا بان
اسرائيل سترد بعد انقضاء اليوم الاول من
عيد الفصح وبالتالي هذا الرد كان مقرا
مسبقا قبل اجتماع
الامني الاسرائيلي الرد على قطاع غزه كان
مقرن بشكل مسبق الان يجري البحث في الشق
الاخر من التطعيد لهذه الليله وهو جبهه
جنوبي لبنان وما اذا كانت اسرائيل سترد ان
لا في تلك الجبهه ايضا
بالنسبه للاجتماع الذي لم ينتهي حتى الان
هل يمكن ان هل من الممكن ومن المتوقع ان
تصدر ايضا عنه قرارات ربما يعني تصعد
الموقف يعني اكثر مما هو عليه الان
فقط الان انتهى انتهى اجتماع الكابينه
الامني الاسرائيلي لم يعلن بعد عن اي
قرارات بطبيعه الحال القرارات هي عملتيه
وبالتالي ليس بالضروره ان تعلن على الملا
هذا امر واضح ولكن انتهت انتهى اجتماع
الحكومه الامنيه المصغره استمرت ثلاث
ساعات ثلاث ساعات راسه بنيامين نتنياهو
وعمليا انتهى هذا الاجتماع سنرى في
الساعات المقبله يعني انا اتواجد الان على
حدود سنرى ايضا في الساعات المقبله عندما
كان التصعيد هذه الليله ايضا سيطال هذه
الجبه ام انه سيقتصر على جبهه قطاع غزه
ربما يكون يعني الامر مريحا اكثر واقل
مجازفه بالنسبه لحكومه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لان معطيات جبهه قطاع غزه
تختلف جذريا عن المعطيات على الجبه
الشماليه نعم طيب زياد يعني سياسيا هل
رصدت اي ردود افعال من الجانب الفلسطيني
صحيح ان هذه الغاره بدات قبل اكثر من نصف
ساعه من الان هل رصدت اي مواقف من الجانب
الفلسطيني حتى الان
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه اعلنت من خلال
غرفه العمليات بانها منذ البدايه ب
انها لاطلاق الصواريخ وهذا ما يتم فعليا
على الارض ربما بعد قليل ايضا سنسمع
السلطه الفلسطينيه تدين وتطالب باجتماع
لمجلس الامن وبتدخل دوري ليس من المستبعد
ابدا خلال الوقت القريب جدا ان تبدا مصر
بمحاولات الوساطه لاحتواء الموقف كي لا
يتطور الى حرب شامله على قطاع غزه اساسا
مصر منذ يومين وهي تحاول احتواء الوضع
ومنع التفاقد الوضع على جبهه قطاع غزه
بسبب ما يحدث من اعتداءات في المسجد
الاقصى وبالتالي سنرى ايضا في الساعات
المقبله وساطه مصريه نشطه بين الجانبين
نعم يعني زياد ابقى معنا اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي قالت ان قالت ان القوات
الاسرائيليه هاجمت مواقع انتاج اسلحه
تابعه لحماس في في غزه
ينضم الينا عبد الحفيظ جعوان
زميلنا اهلا بك هل لديك اي معلومات جديده
متوفره اي تفاصيل تتعلق بهذه الغاره التي
بدات قبل اكثر من نصف ساعه من الان
باتجاه قطاع غزه
هناك بيان من حركه حماس صدر قبل قليل يحمل
اسرائيل المسؤوليه عن النجوم على قطاع غزه
وايضا المصادر الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن اطلاق
ثمانيه صواريخ من قطاع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات الغلاف والمدن الاسرائيليه
القريبه من قطاع غزه وتقول المصادر
الاسرائيليه انه يعني تم اعتراض معظم هذه
الصواريخ الثمانيه التي اطلقت من قطاع غزه
الفصل الفلسطينيه تقول ان ستواصل اطلاق
الصواريخ من غزه باتجاه المستوطنات وقد
توسع دائره الاستهداف في حال استمرت
الغارات الاسرائيليه او تغير نوعها حتى
الان الحديث عن الكثافه صحيحه للغارات
الاسرائيليه ولكن نبقى في اطار التصعيد
المضبوط بمعنى ان الغارات الاسرائيليه حتى
هذه اللحظه تستهدف مناطق زراعيه
معسكرات تدريب ومناطق
ابراجهم مراقبه تم اخلائها سابقا وبالتالي
عدم ايقاع الضحايا وعدم ارساله دماء من
هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه من شانه ايضا ان
يحد من رد الفصائل الفلسطينيه
مكمن ونوعا يعني من عدد الصواريخ او
الصواريخ التي قد تستهدف مدن اسرائيليه
رئيسيه في الداخل هذا بخصوص قطاع الضفه
الغربيه لا تقل توترا ايضا
دعوات من الفصائل الفلسطينيه بشكل عام
للخروج بتظاهرات الان
للتضامن مع قطاعه غزه وضد هذا التصعيد
الاسرائيلي ايضا هناك مواجهات في عده
مناطق في نابلس وفي الخليل وايضا في احياء
من مدينه القدس مع القوات الاسرائيليه
وايضا هناك عمليات عمليتين اطلاق نار حتى
هذه اللحظه تم تسجيلها او ثلاث عمليات
هناك عمليه جديده ايضا في طولكرم
المجموعات المسلحه بدات تنشط بشكل كبير
خلال الايام الاخيره وخصوصا مع التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في المسجد الاقصى الذي يعتبر
يعني مربط الفرس لاي حراك ميداني او تصعيد
ميداني يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه سواء
الضفه الغربيه غزه نعم عبد الحفيظ يعني
السلطات الاسرائيليه قامت باتخاذ العديد
من التدابير قبل بدايه هذه الغاره الجويه
التي بدات قبل اكثر من نصف ساعه من الان
يعني
فتحت الملاجئ العامه التحسبا لاي تدهور
امني يمكن ان ان يحدث كذلك الملاجئ التي
فتحت فيه عسقلان وايضا المستوطنات في حدود
قطاع غزه اود ان اسال هل هنالك ايا من
التدابير التي اتخذت من قبل الجانب
الفلسطيني او من قبل السلطات في قطاع غزه
تحسبا لهذه الغاره التي كانت متوقعه
الامكانيات محدوده جدا في قطاع غزه
امكانيه الحمايه على المستوى المدني لا
يوجد ملاجئ في قطاع غزه ليلجا اليها
المواطنون ولكن في مثل هذه الحالات عندما
يكون التصعيد يعني يلوح في الافق
وسوف يحدث هو الناس متاكدون من ذلك عاده
ما يبتعدون عن بعض المناطق التي تعتبر
معسكرات تدريب تتبع لفصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي
شعبيا الامور على حالها صحيا وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اعلنت كافه طواقمها ووضعت كافه
الامكانيات في حاله طوارئ
للتجهيز لاي اصابات قد تحدث نتيجه في هذا
هذه الغارات المتواصله عسكريا الفصائل
الفلسطينيه قامت بسحب مختلف العناصر من
سواء المعسكرات التدريب او ابراج المراقبه
ونشاهدنا ايضا هناك تجهيز لبعض الصواريخ
ارض جو المحموله على الكتف والذي اطلقت
هذه الليله مرتين باتجاه الطائرات
الاسرائيليه المغيره على قطاع غزه
وبالتالي يعني التجهيز عاده يجري بشكل
عفوي
وفق الامكانيات المتاحه بعكس الجانب
الاسرائيلي الذي حتى يعني فتح بلديه
ديمونه مثلا اعلنت عن فتح الملاجئ وهي
التي تبعد اكثر من 200 كيلو متراعي غزه
وبالتالي باسرائيل يستعدون لكافه
السيناريوهات
يعني المتوقعه يفتحون الملاجئ ويضعون كافه
الامكانيات
يعني موجه اي تصعيد قد يجري نتيجه هذه
الغارات المتواصله نعم ويبدا الان الرد
المقابل على اعتبار ان هيئه البث
الاسرائيلي تقول ان ثمانيه صواريخ اطلقت
من قطاع غزه على مستوطنات اسرائيليه وكذلك
ايضا قبل قليل يعني يعني الفصائل
الفلسطينيه تحدثت عن انها ستواصل اطلاق
الصواريخ من قطاع غزه اذا استمرت الغارات
الاسرائيليه عبد الحفيظ ساتركك قليلا
لمعرفه المزيد من المعلومات يعني تاتي هذه
الاسرائيليه مشاهدينا بالتزامن مع انتهاء
اجتماع الحكومه الامنيه المصغره كما ذكر
مراسلنا قبل قليل فيما دعى قبل ذلك رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامنه نياهو الى
تهدئه التوترات وقال ان اسرائيل ستعمل
بحزم ضد من يستخدم العنف واكد الا رغبه في
تغيير الوضع الراهن للاماكن المقدسه في
القدس كما اضاف سنضرب بقوه وسيدفع من
وصفهم بالاعداء الثمن كانت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اشارت الى ان التقييم الامني
الاولي هو ان هجوما في غزه ولبنان سينفذ
الليله وذلك بعد ان اطلقت صواريخ من جنوب
لبنان الى الاراضي الاسرائيليه في وقت
سابق
سنعمل بقوه ضد المتطرفين الذين يلجاون
لاستخدام العنف ضدنا وبالنسبه للاستهداف
من الجهه الاخرى سنضرب اعدائنا وسيدفعون
ثمن عدوانيتهم وسيكتشفون كيف الشعب
الاسرائيلي بغض النظر عن كل الخلافات من
اجل الدفاع عن دولتنا وشعبنا
معنى الان مشاهدينا من قطاع غزه الصحفي
احمد حرب اهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه
المفتوحه للتطورات لما يجري في قطاع غزه
الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل قليل تحدث عن انه
استهدف موقعين لتصنيع الاسلحه
يتبعان لحماس هل نحن امام عمليه نوعيه ام
اننا امام مواجهه مفتوحه الان
يعني ربما نحن امام عمليه جراحيه تقوم بها
[موسيقى]
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
واسرائيل في قطاع غزه من خلال استهداف
مواقع عسكريه من العيار الثقيل تستخدمها
المقاومه او الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
التصنيع يعني الادوات العسكريه وايضا من
خلال استهداف العديد من اراضي الزراعيه
الفارغه التي ربما تستخدم من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه في اطلاق التواريخ العمليه
العسكريه الى الان لم تبدا بشكل كبير
ورقعه الزيت لم تتسع في قطاع غزه على
الرغم من ان اسرائيل اعلنت ان هذه العمليه
اطلقت عليها اسم اليد القويه ولكن حتى هذه
اللحظه عمليا وعمالاتيا عملاتيا على الارض
لم يكن هناك
استهدافات كبيره كما شهدناها في
الحروب السابقه على قطاع غزه حتى هذه
اللحظه الاستهدافات في اماكن محدوده وفي
مواقع محدوده وفي مناطق مختلفه من مقابل
وانا اتحدث اليك الان كانت هناك
الفصائل تواصل اطلاق الصواريخ من قطاع غزه
باتجاه المستوطنات المحاديه للقطاع
ووصلت هذه الصواريخ الى مستوطنات ونير عام
وتفارات الانذار تدوي الان في هذه
المستوطنات في المقابل المضادات التي
تستخدمها الفصاله الفلسطينيه في توجيهها
ضد الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في النصف
ساعه الماضيه ربما اطلقت عددا منها تجاه
الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه نحن الان في فعل ورده فعل في
القطاع الساعات القادمه هي سيده الموقف
والميدان هو سيد الموقف في في القطاع بسبب
ان هذه
العمليه العسكريه
رده الفعل الاسرائيليه هي جاءت بعد يعني
اطلاق اكثر من 30 صاروخ من لبنان
والاصابع الاتهام الاسرائيليه وجهتها الى
حركه حماس بها القطاع هي من تقوم بتوجيه
هذه المجموعات في لبنان واطلاق هذه
الصواريخ التالي
قطاع غزه يعني سوف يشهد خلال الساعات
القادمه
استهدافات متعدده ولربما الاعلام
الاسرائيليه يتحدث بان سوف تكون هناك جوله
تصعيد لايام يشهدها القطاع ولكن يعني
الساعات القادمه والميدان هو من سيحدد
الموقف هذه الاثناء بالطبع ربما الاتصالات
من الوسطاء سواء من مصر والاردن والامم
المتحده ربما تجري من اجل وقف هذا التصعيد
في القطاع وايضا قبل قليل هناك بيان
للرئاسه الفلسطينيه تحدثت فيه بانها تجري
الاتصالات المكثفه مع مصر والاردن
وامريكا من اجل التدخل ووقف هذا التصعيد
في المسجد الاقصى والقدس وفي قطاع غزه هذه
الاتصالات وهذه الوصفات المكثفه ربما تنجح
في يعني وقف هذه الوقف هذا التصعيد في
القطاع ولكن
الميدان كما تحدثت هو سيد الموقف ربما
نشهد مزيد من اتساع رقعه الزيت في القطاع
وبالتالي سوف ندخل في عمليه عسكريه واسعه
تمتد لايام او يعني نبقى في حاله هذه هذه
الردود النسبيه من قبل الفطائر الفلسطينيه
في القطاع وايضا من قبل اسرائيل نعم استاذ
احمد يعني وانت الان موجود في قطاع غزه
ولدينا الان صوره على الهواء مباشره صوره
لغزه الان وايضا صوره لغزه قبل قليل حيث
انت صف لي المشهد حاله الناس حاله
المواطنين في قطاع غزه
يعني الوضع في القطاع غزه هو حالا من
الحذر والترقب والتوتر على المستوى الشعبي
في القطاع الاوضاع الانسانيه والاقتصاديه
صعبه جدا على المواطن الفلسطيني في القطاع
الذي يعني هو يعيش في دوامه
التوتر ويعيش ايضا في
ازمات وحلقه من الازمات المتتاليه التي
يعني تنغص عليه كل شيء فبالتالي
تفعيل اسرائيل من هذا النوع هو سوف يزيد
الصين بل لدى المواطن حاله الخوف والهلع
في اوساط
العائلات الفلسطينيه والمواطنين
الفلسطينيه حاصله بكل تاكيد وموجوده بسبب
ان غزه لم تحتمل ان يكون هناك
حرب اسرائيليه خامسه على قطاع غزه سوف
يعني
كافه
المقومات الحياه في القطاع التي يعني تشهد
تدهورا متزايدا بشكل كبير خلال السنوات
الماضيه هناك
المستويات المختلفه في القطاع تعاني كثيرا
هناك عدد من الابنيه لم عمليه الاعمار في
القطاع غزه
لم تكن بشكل كبير
تتقدم خلال السنوات الماضيه بسبب يعني ضعف
التمويل وبالتالي يعني
قدوم او يعني وجود حرب او تصعيد اسرائيل
يكون كبير في في قطاع غزه هذا سوف يعني
ينهك المواطن الفلسطيني الذي يعاني
الويلات جراء الحصار الاسرائيلي المستمر
منذ اكثر من 15 عاما على القطاع وبالتالي
حاله او المشهد الانساني وفي القطاع صعب
جدا وهذا يعني يضعنا في مازق ويضع المواطن
الفلسطيني في مازق كبير وهذا
يستدعي وهذا ما استدعى الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
ان تقوم على الفور باجراء اتصالات من اجل
وقف التصعيد في القطاع نعم استاذ احمد حرب
الصحفي من غزه ارجو ان تبقى معنا لمتابعه
كل التطورات التي تحدث الان في قطاع غزه
انتقل الى الاستاذ عماد ابو عواد خبير في
الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه
المباشره من العربيه هل من مصلحه اسرائيل
الدخول في مواجهه مفتوحه الان وبهذا الشكل
في قطاع غزه
تحياتي لك لجمهور المشاهدين بالتاكيد
لاسرائيل في السنوات الاخيره ربما واذا ما
عدنا الى الاستراتيجيه التي بناها افيف
كوخافي وهو رئيس هيئه الاركان السابق في
دوله الاحتلال ارتكزت الامر الاول ان يتم
استبعاد الحرب قدر الامكان والامر الثاني
ان يكون هناك حاله من يعني
الاستعداد الى ان تكون الحرب قصيره المدى
قدر الامكان تالي هذه القضيه جوهريه في
هذا السياق واسرائيل تعي حاليا بانه لا
يمكن ان يكون هناك حاله حربيه مستمره في
ظل الانقسام الداخلي الاسرائيلي وفي ظل
الشعور العام بان الواقع في اسرائيل حقيقه
لا لن يؤدي الى حسم اي معركه واي حرب وفي
ظل القناعات الاسرائيليه ان المعارك بشكل
او باخر لن تؤدي الى تغيير الواقع الموجود
حاليا نعم طيب استاذ عماد يعني هل نستطيع
عن القول بان هذه الغاره التي بدات الان
هي خطوه اولى لمساله فصل الجبهات بين
الشمال والجنوب هذه العمليه التي كانت
تنويها اسرائيل وهذا ما تريده اسرائيل ان
تفصل الجبهات بين شمال والجنوب
يعني انا استبعد ان اسرائيل معنيه بتوحيد
الجبهات لذلك هي قدر الامكان نعم تركز على
قطاع غزه وتحمل غزه المسؤوليه من هذا
المنطلق
نعم يبدو ان الاتصال قد انقطع بالسيد عماد
ابو عواد خبير في اشياءنا الاسرائيلي على
اي حال نتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
وتطورات الاحداث هنالك في قطاع غزه
ننتقل الى زميلنا عبد الحفيظ جعوان هل
لديك اي معلومات جديده
هناك تصريح
لوزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قلن يقول انه
يعني اسرائيل جاهزه للرد على كافه
التهديدات وعلى كل الجبهات ايضا هناك
اخبار متداوله محليا بان وسطاء ابلغ
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان هذا الرد
الاسرائيلي هو على اطلاق الصواريخ من غزه
خلال اليومين السابقين وليس ردا على اطلاق
الصواريخ هذا اليوم من الجنوب لبناني
وبالتالي
يعني الغارات حدثت وحدثت بشكل كثيف الان
نرى تراجعا لحدتها كما ذكرتم سابقا بيان
للجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه استهدف نفطين
نفق في شمال قطاع غزه حنون ونفق في جنوب
قطاع غزه قربه خان يونس وايضا اماكن يقول
انها لتصنيع الاسلحه لحركه حماس وسط قطاع
غزه في هذه الاثناء ايضا الصافات الانذار
دوت من ثلاث الى اربع مرات في المستوطنات
المحيطه في قطاع غزه وتحديدا اصدارات ونير
عام وغيرها من المعسكرات الاسرائيليه
المحيطه والحديث عن
عشره صواريخ تقريبا اطلقت من من هذا
القطاع من قطاع غزه باتجاه هذه المستوطنات
وتم اعتراض اغلبها وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ايضا المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
اشرق القدره قال انه لم تصل حتى هذه
اللحظه اي اصابه في صفوف المدنيين او حتى
العسكريين من قطاع غزه اجراء هذه الغارات
الى المشافي وان المشافي موضوعه في حاله
استنفار كبير خشيه من تدهور الامور
الميدانيه نعم وعندما يقول وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يعني ان اسرائيل مستعده لكافه
الاحتمالات هل هذا يعني اننا امام
ربما يعني
تصعيد قد يطول امده في هذا القطاع
في تصريح وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي او حتى
في الاخبار المتداوله عن الرد
الاسرائيلي يخص اليومين السابقين ولا يخص
هذا اليوم ان اسرائيل ربما ايضا
تهاجم اهدافا في الجنوب اللبناني تابعه
لفصائل الفلسطينيه او لحزب الله او غيرها
وبالتالي عندما يقال ان اسرائيل جاهز للرد
على
كافه الاخطار التي تحيط بها من كل اماكن
ربما يقصد بذلك انه ربما نشهد ايضا هذا
هذه الليله باتجاه مواقع اخرى غير استطاع
غزه
طيب عبد الحفيظ جعوان انا اتمنى ان تبقى
معنا سنتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه
وهذه الصور التي يعني اتتنا قبل قليل من
غزه صور للقصف الاسرائيلي الغاره
الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت مواقع عسكريه
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انها الواقع لتصنيع
السلاح تتبع لحركه حماس كما قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي الفصائل الفلسطينيه قالت بانها
ستواصل اطلاق الصواريخ من قطاع غزه اذا
استمرت الغارات الاسرائيليه على اي حال
نحن ايضا بانتظار البيان الذي ستخرج منه
يعني او سيخرج منه اجتماع الحكومه الامنيه
المصغره التي انتهى قبل ربع ساعه تقريبا
بحسب ما افاد مراسل العربيه يعني نتابع
معكم هذه الصور التي تاتينا الان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن ان عن نظام
الامني الاسرائيلي مجهز بشكل كبير على
كافه الاصعده اذن يعني بطبيعه الحال هذه
التوترات الذي التي بدات قبل ايام منذ
اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه باحات المسجد
الاقصى وقامت ايضا
الاجلاء المصلين بالقوه وقامت باطلاق
الغاز المسيل للدموع وايضا اطلاق القنابل
الصوتيه داخل اباحات المسجد الاقصى هذا
الامر يقول البعض انه ادى الى كل هذه
التوترات الكبيره التي تشهدها
المنطقه على اعتبار انها يعني او ترتب على
اثرها هذا الرد رد الفعل الذي كان صباح
هذا اليوم باطلاق اكثر من 30 صاروخ يعني
باتجاه اسرائيل على اعتبار ان هذا الامر
كان فيه رد لما حدث قبل ايام في بحات
المسجد الاقصى سريعا جاء الرد الاسرائيلي
باتجاه قطع غزه
بدات هذه الغاره قبل حوالي ساعه من الان
على مواقع في قطاع غزه الان ينضم الينا
مجددا مدير مكتب العربيه في الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك
مجددا هل لديك اي معلومات جديده
فيما هذه الجبهه الامور هادئه حاليا
الحكومه الاذيه المصغره بعد ان انها ثلاث
ساعات من المداولات اصدرت قبل دقائق بينما
مقتضبا
لانها اتخذ
ت قرارات بناء على توصيات جميع الامنيه
والجيش الاسرائيلي في اشاره الى ان
الحكومه تبنت توصيات الجيش الاسرائيلي ردا
على الاستهداف لاسرائيل من الجنوبي
والشمال كما قال البيان نتنياهو قال ان
رد الفعل سيكون موزعا لاعدائنا على حد
وصفه الواضح هو بان الثقل الاكبر من هذا
الرد وكما توقعنا منذ عمليا
هو ما نراه الان في قطاع غزه الغارات على
قطاع غزه التي قد تقول انها يعني غير
مسبوقه في الاشهر المعيبه هذه غارات واسعه
في النطاق طبعا حتى الساعه اطلقت صواريخ
على الاقل اعترضت عدد من الصواريخ من قبل
البطاريات القبه الحديديه
وعضليه الغارات
نعم زياد ابقى معنا يعني هنالك الكثير من
العواجل التي تظهر الان اسفل الشاشه يعني
الان مصادر للعربيه تتحدث عن ان اسرائيل
ترفض وقف العمليات العسكريه الحاليه كما
ان ايضا مصادر العربيه تحدثت قبل قليل ان
مسؤولون امنيون مصريون يتواصلون مع
اسرائيل بعد قرارها بقصف قطاع غزه اذن
هنالك ايضا يعني حديث من مصادر للعربيه عن
تاجيل زياره وفود مصريه الى غزه وتل ابيب
نتيجه الغارات الحاليه هنالك ايضا اتصالات
مصريه بحسب المصادر اتصالات مصريه موسعه
مع الجانب الامريكي والاسرائيلي وايضا
الفصائل للتهدئه مصادر للعربيه ايضا اكدت
ان مسؤولون كما تحدثنا قبل قليل مسؤولون
المصريون طالبوا اسرائيل بوقف الضربات
العسكريه وكما طالبوا ايضا يعني بضروره
التهدئه هنالك ايضا مصادر للعربيه تحدثت
عن ان اسرائيل ترفض وقف العمليات العسكريه
الحاليه
المصادر اكدت ايضا ان مصر طالبت اسرائيل
بضروره عدم استهداف المدنيين والمدن
السكنيه اذا نحن الان على اعتاب تحركات
سريحه سريعه وعاجله ومستعجله تحركات مصريه
بدات الان في محاوله
للتهدئه زياد هل تسمعني
نعم يبدو ان الاتصال قد انقطع بمدير مكتب
العربيه في القدس زياد حلبيه ينضم الينا
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه عصمت منصور
اهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه المباشره يعني هل
من الممكن ان تسفر هذه التحركات المصريه
المستعجله والتي تدعو يعني في البدء الى
التهدئه
يعني تدعو الجميع الجانب الاسرائيلي وكذلك
ايضا الفصائل الفلسطينيه هل يمكن ان تفسر
ان تسفر هذه التحركات عن حلول عاجله على
الاقل توقف حده التصعيد في هذه المنطقه
تحياتي لكم يعني بالفعل هذا ربما الهدف
الان الكل يدرك انه اسرائيل لن تتجاوب
يعني بعد الصف على الاطراكتها اليوم لن
تتجاوب سريعا مع هذه الجهود لكن هذه
القناه وخاصه القناه المصريه مهمه جدا هذه
قناه لها خبره طويل
والتحظى بفكره كل الاطراف ويمكن ان تلعب
دور اعتقد انه هدف هذه الاتصالات الان في
هذه المرحله ان لا تصل الامور الى نقطه
تصبح فيها المواجهه مفتوحه
وسيطر عليها يصبح متعذرا الهدف ان يكون
التصعيد محدود لكي يتم احتوائه خلال ايام
يعني بعد ان تقوم اسرائيل بردها
الذي يعني يشعرها انها ردت واعاده
الاعتبار لقوه رابعها وايضا ان تكون
التصرف عندها يمكن البدء بالحديث عن نوع
من التعبئه وترتيبات امنيه هذه نتيجه مت
لمثل هذه الصلاه على مستوى يعني الاهداف
ماذا يمكن ان تحقق اسرائيل لا يوجد اهداف
ملموسه يمكن ان تحققها حسن لا يمكن الوصول
لحسن وبالقنوات وبالرسائل العسكريه لوحدها
من المتعذر الوصول الى نتائج مباشره ولكن
بعد ان يعني يتم الرد اعتقد انه يعني يمكن
البدء بالحديث وهنا اعتقد الدور المصري
مدعوما بالموقف الامريكي يمكن ان يلعب دور
وايضا الموقف الاسرائيلي صار رغم كل ما
نقول الان
وعن قوه التدمير التي يمكن ان تمارسها
اسرائيل موقف نتنياهو الداخلي صعب موقف
اسرائيل العسكري صعب بل بادر الى الهجوم
واخطار التوقيت وكان على جهوزيه هو الذي
ضرب اولا واسرائيل بوغتت وهي في ربما اسوا
اوضاعها استراتيجيا في هذه الفتره لذلك
تحاول ان تعيد الاعتبار
لقوه ربيعها ولمكانتها واندوس الرسائل من
خلال قصف ربما يكون شديد وقوي هذه المره
ومن ثم تبدا بالتجاوب مع هذه
الدعوات الى التهدئه على قاعده عوده
الامور كما كانت عليه نحن في نهايه شهر
رمضان نحن في فتره حساسه جدا في الضفه
والقدس والجبهه التي فتحت مؤخرا في لبنان
هذا نعم
به استاذ عصمت يعني اسمح لي يعني الان
يظهر عاجل نتنياهو بعد اجتماع الحكومه
الامنيه يقول ان الرد الاسرائيلي من
الليله وبعدها سيكلف اعداءنا ثمنا باهظا
هذا يؤشر الى ان هذا الرد بدا اليوم ولكنه
لن ينتهي اليوم
لا يمكن ان ينتهي اليوم هذا يعني هذا
المتوقع على كل حال واللهجه التي تتحدث
بها نتنياهو لهجه مالوفه في مثل هكذا يعني
اجواء هذا عمليا موجه للداخل وايضا ربما
يعني موجه
فصل المقاومه
الدول ربما خلفها والتي تتهمها اسرائيل
انها هي التي تحرك هذه
التصعيد هذه عمليه التصعيد لذلك نعم يعني
هذا ما يكون
متوقع جدا
ما هو يشير انه الرد سيكون شديد لكن هل
يطول هل يطال
اهداف تغير ميزان المعادله بمعنى ان يتم
استهداف قيادات هل يتم اللجوء الى كافه
ابراج يعني هذه المؤشرات تعطينا صوره اوضح
عن طبيعه الاسرائيلي اما اذا كان ضد منشاه
عسكريه وضد اهداف وقواعد تدريب وغيرها
وايضا كان رد المقاومه في اطار غلاف غزه
ولا يصل الى تل ابيب مثلا او مدن اسبانيه
كبيره اعتقد عندها يمكن احتواء الموقف نعم
انت كيف تفسر الاهداف التي استهدفت حتى
الان يعني اسرائيل تتحدث عن انها وحتى
الان استهدفت مواقع لتصنيع الاسلحه تابعه
لحماس كيف تفسر طبيعه هذا الهجوم حتى الان
هذا هجوم اعتقد انه اولي ربما هذا الهجوم
بدا اثناء الكبريت يعني قبل ان تنتهي جلسه
هذا فيه الرساله انه هذا الرد على الاحداث
السابقه
انه اسرائيل
تعرضت او كان هناك قصص بالصواريخ من يومين
وعلى خلفيه احداث الاقصى والاعتداء على
المصلين والمعتكين لذلك ربما يكون هذا
الرد كانت الضرور موضوع جانبا وتم تفعيله
الان كرد اولي لكن الرد الحقيقي على ما
حدث اليوم سيكون بعد جلسه الكبريت وخلال
هذه الليله
والساعات القادمه انا افترض انه الرد
سيكون ليس سهلا ربما نشهد ايام صعبه
ومواجهه تمتد لايام قبل ان يتم احتوائها
وكل شيء يتوقف على كيف تختار اسرائيل
اهدافها وايضا الطريقه التي ترد بها
المقاومه وهنا بالذات ياتي دور الوسطاء
وجهودهم وامكانيه تاثيرهم على سيره
الوسطاء استاذ عصمت يعني مصادر العربيه
تتحدث عن ان اسرائيل ابلغت مصر ان تصعيدها
متوقف على رد الفص الفلسطينيه اي انها
الان تنتظر ما ستفعله الفصائل يعني وبعدها
سيكون هنالك يعني رد اخر من السلطات او او
من الجانب الاسرائيلي على الاقل
اذا كان هذا الرد بالفعل اعتقد انه هذا
مؤشر على انه الامور لن تكون يعني جبهه
مفتوحه الفصائل حتى الان ردها في غلاف غزه
في مناطق قريبه وفي مناطق تقريبا مفتوحه
وهذا ايضا ربما رساله من الفصائل انها
ربما تكتفي بهذا الرد اذا توقفت اسرائيل
لذلك يعني اذا بقيت الامور في هذا النطاق
ربما يمكن احتوائها خلال 24 ساعه الى 48
ساعه لكن اذا اسرائيل
وسعت نطاق هجماتها ربما تبيت حاله من
الغدر ربما تريد ان تستدرج
الفصائل المقاومه الى نوع من الاسترخاء
واظهار وكانه اكتفت بالرد كي تباغت لانه
من بدا ومن امتلك زمام المبادره هو
الفصائل وهذا الوضع غير مريح لاسرائيل غير
هي ضبطت غير جاهزه في وضع داخلي صعب
شهر رمضان في ظل اعياد يهوديه في ظل
انتسام داخلي في ظل ازمه مع وزير الدفاع
يعني هذا الوضع والتوقيت لا ليس المثالي
لاسرائيل لذلك ربما تبرر بعض
السعيد هي المبادره
وهذا غير مستبعد على الاطلاق خاصه نتنياهو
لا اصبح نعم
يبقى معنا يعني دعنا ننتقل الى زميلنا
الاستاذ زياد حلبي مدير المكتب العربيه في
القدس يعني هل حمل البيان يعني الذي صدر
قبل قليل من الحكومه الامنيه المصغره حمل
اي جديد ان كانت لديك معلومات ضعنا في
صوره هذا البيان
البيان كان مقتضبا قال ان الحكومه الامنيه
المصغره اتخذت سلسله قرارات بناء على
التوصيات الجيش الاسرائيلي واجهزه الامن
وطبعا اضيفها بان اسرائيل
فتدفع الجهات التي قامت باطلاقها الصواريخ
الثمن الملاحظ في البيان كانت تشديد على
ان الحكومه تعتقد قرارا بناء على قرارات
الزيت او توثيات الجيش الاسرائيلي وليس من
باب المصادفه لان
الحكومه تخشى بانها بسبب الازمه الداخليه
في اسرائيل لا تكون ثقه في الشارع
الاسرائيلي بحرب تقوم بها هذه الحكومه
سواء شمالا او جنوبا لان هناك من قد يعتقد
بانها تحاول ان تهرب من الازمه الداخليه
لهذا هذه الفقره الوحيده التي اورثت عمليا
في
تقول باننا قبلنا ما قاله الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذه الحكومه المصغره طبعا
البيان تحدث عن ان الرد الحالي والمقبل
على اطلاق الصواريخ من الشمال والجنوب
اساسا كما كان متوقعا منذ البدايه بان
الثقل الاساسي للرب الاسرائيلي سيكون على
حساب قطاع غزه لان هذه جبهه تبقى اكثر
قابليه للسيطره واقل ترتيبا وخطوره من
الجبهه الجبليه مع حزب الله لهذا ليس
واضحا حتى ان كانت اسرائيل سترد على
الغارات من جنوب لبنان بقصر في جنوب لبنان
رمزيا
الفرضيه تظل قائمه صحيح
هذا صحيح طبعا هذا مت
وقع
ما لفتني هذه المره بانه اسرائيل كانت ترد
خلال دقائق او ساعه على اطلاق من جنوب
لبنان هذا لم يحصل هذه المره واحده تجاه
جنوب لبنان وماذا يعني ذلك يا زياد
لا تريد ان تقترب كثيرا من جبهه جنوب
لبنان لانها تدعاتها اعمق واكبر بكثير لا
مقارنه بين الصواريخ والقدرات التي تملكها
حزب الله وبين التي تملكها الفصائل حاليا
في قطاع غزه
من حيث كثافه النيران وال
اساس النيران وهذا هو المتغير الاساسي
عمليا لاحظنا منذ الاتفاق الذي تم توقيعه
بين
لبنان بالله بانه في حال لم يوقع فيضرب
مواقع الغاز الاسرائيليه مرورا بعمليه مجد
الاخيره التي حملت اسرائيل حزب الله بشكل
واضح وصولا الى اطلاق الصواريخ من جنوب
لبنان في في هذه الامور عمليا هناك تاكل
المراقبين باسرائيل في المعادله الردع
بنسبه لاسرائيل على جبهه الشماليه ولهذا
عدم الرد قد يفهم على انه خشيه من الرد
هذا ما يقول خبراء في اسرائيل لهذا تبقى
فرضيه رد رمزي على الاقل قائمه على هذه
الجبهه في جنوب لبنان لكن الثقل الاساسي
بات واضحه بان سيكون على حساب قطاع هذا
ملكتني ايضا بان الاعلام الاسرائيلي اوقف
البث المباشر كل الاقنيه الاسرائيليه عادت
الى برامجها العاديه لا اعرف ان كان ذلك
يكللل على شيء من جهه ما يحدث الان مع
قطاع غزه ام لا ولكنه كان امر لا خفا بان
البث توقف في القنوات الاسرائيليه حاليا
نعم ابقى معنا زياد حلبي مدير مكتب
العربيه في القدس ينضم الينا الخبير في
شؤون الاسرائيليه
او عبد الحفيظ جعوان عفوا ينضم الينا عبد
الحفيظ يعني هل لديك اي معلومات
مستجدات تتعلق بتفاصيل هل هنالك اي انباء
عن خسائر جديده جراء هذا القصف
بالنسبه للساعه الاخيره فقط غار اسرائيليه
وحيده تمت بطائره بدون طياره على ايضا
منطقه خاليه في بيت حانون الشمال قطاعي
غزه وايضا دوت صفارات الانظار مره اخرى في
مستوطنات
المستوطنات المحاديه للقطاع الدفاع المدني
الفلسطينيه يتحدث عن انهيار اجزاء من مبنى
في قطاع غزه مبنى سكاني بسبب ارتجاج الارض
نتيجه لحده الغارات التي حدثت بشكل متزامن
قبل نحو ساعه ولكن لا يوجد اصابات نتيجه
هذا الانهيار ايضا وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
في قطاع غزه تقول ان لا اصابات نتيجه
التصعيد الاسرائيلي نتيجه العراق
الاسرائيليه هذا من جانب الاسرائيلي من
الجانب الفلسطيني هناك بيانين واحد لكتائب
المقاومه الوطنيه واخر لكتائب المجاهدين
يتبنى اطلاق الصواريخ التي رب عشره مصادر
اسرائيليه التي اطلقت باتجاه مستوطنات
الغلاف ايضا ان يعني
كتاب القسام التابعه لحماس او حتى الجهاد
وهي كبرى الحركتين يعني في قطاع غزه التي
تملكان صواريخ متوسطه وبعيده المذاه انجاز
التعبير لم تنخرطان في الرد على بشكل
مباشر في الرد على الغارات الاسرائيليه
وان كانت قد
اطلقت بعض الصواريخ ارض جو المحموله على
الكتف باتجاه الطائرات الاسرائيليه وربما
اكتفت يعني هذه الفصائل بهذا الرد على
الطائرات هناك يعني التراجع لحده الغراض
كما قلت والامور تميل
للتهدئه او ربما الاحتواء نظرا لدخول جهود
مصريه بشكل مباشر على خط
التصعيد ومحاوله لاحتواء هذا الامر
وبالتالي سنركب خلال الساعات القادمه
ايضا هناك تصريح يعني نتنياهو كان لافتا
بشان
الرد سيستمر لايام وايضا المحللين بدوي
يتحدثون ان نتنياهو لا يمكن ان يكتفي برد
رغم التوصيات المستوى العسكري
بان يعني يكون الرد فقط محدودا ان النت
يهرب ربما لم يستطع صد المطالبات من
حلفائه في الحكومه وتحديدا
الذين يضغطون على نتنياهو اللي
يعني اظهار قوه كافيه وكبيره للجانب
الاسرائيلي هو يطالبونه بتنفيذ عمليات
اغتيال ضد قيادات فلسطينيه تحديدا في قطاع
غزه خلال الساعات القادمه ربما تميل
الامور الى الهدوء وربما يعني مره اخرى
نشاهد غارات عنيفه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
هناك فراج جح في المشهد العسكري التعبير
في قطاع غزه خلال نص ساعه الاخيره نعم طيب
عبد الحفيظ يعني انت قبل قليل تحدثت عن ان
يعني هنالك كانت غاره بطائره مسيره اود ان
اعرف منك المنهجيه التي يتبعها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في هذا القصف الذي يجري الان
على قطاع غزه هل يتم بواسطه المسيرات
بواسطه الطيران طيران الجيش الاسرائيلي
اود ان اعرف طبيعه هذه او طبيعه الاسلحه
المستخدمه في هذا الهجوم
نعم هناك عده اشكال للقصف الذي يتم على
قطاعه غزه ابرزه من طائرات اف 16
تغير على القطاع يعني
ارتفاعات عاليه جدا وربما يعني طقس مواقع
في قطاع غزه من مناطق بعيده ولكن ابرز
القصف ياتي من طائرات بدون طيار وهي اصلا
موجوده على مدار الساعه فوق قطاع غزه وهذه
الطائرات اما تستهدف بصواريخ ثقيله بعض
الاماكن العسكريه او ما تسميها اسرائيل
اماكن تصنيع اسلحه او تستهدف بصواريخ يعني
صغيره ومحدوده بعض الخلايا الفلسطينيه
التي تحاول اطلاق صواريخ على قطاع غزه اذا
اغتص عاده يتم بالطائرات اما مسيره واما
الطائرات النفاثه الطائرات المروحيه
استبعدت منذ فتره طويله من الغرض على قطاع
غزه وذلك بسبب حصول الفصائل الفلسطينيه
على اسلحه
والدفعه طرديه اما يعني برصاص كثير واما
مضادات اسلحه محموله على الكتف ايضا بعض
عمليات تتم من الظوارق الحربيه الموجوده
في البحر وعاده ما تستهدف هذه الظوارق
يعني اماكن قريبه من الشاطئ قطاع غزه الان
هناك ايضا رشقه صاروخيه جديده من من قطاع
غزه صفارات الانذار فعلت ولا نعرف الاماكن
التي تمت استهدافها نعم
معسكرات قريبه في في غلاف قطاع غزه هناك
ثلاثه اشكال ايضا للقصف لابد للاشاره
اليها واحد من هذه الاشكال هو ما يجبل هذه
الليله وهو استهداف مناطق خاليه معسكرات
تدريب وعاده ما تكون مخلاه ويكون هذا الخص
في اطار التصعيد المضبوط هناك ايضا عمليات
قصر هناك ايضا عمليات تتم وهذا ما تؤدي
الى تصعيد كبير وهناك ايضا كشف اماكن
وامراض من السكنيه لها في السنوات السابقه
خلال تصعيد كبير هذه الليله القصف من
الشكل الاول وهو التصعيد القابل للاحتواء
والذي يستهدف مؤثرات خاليه واماكن تدريب
اذن اخر الاخبار الانذار مجددا في
مستوطنات الغلاف عنده دقائق ايضا غاره
اسرائيليه بطائره بدون طيار تحاول استهداف
هذه الخلايا التي تقوم باطلاق المخطوطات
الصاروخيه على حدود قطاعي غزه على
المستوطنات القريبه وعاده هذه الخلايا اما
تستخدم انفاقا تحت الاشجار او حتى بدراجات
ناريه يعني تاتي بصاروخ محمود تطلقه وتكون
بالقرار من المكان وتلاحقها بعد ذلك
الطائرات بدون طيار طيب عبد الحفيظ اود ان
اعرف منك قليلا يعني المزيد من التفاصيل
المتعلقه بتفاصيل تقنيه بشان طبيعه
الاسلحه التي تمتلكها الفصائل الفلسطينيه
هل تمتلك يعني مضادات او
تمتلك يعني اسلحه تستطيع ان تقاوم طائرات
الاف 16 وايضا المسيرات التي يمتلكها
الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالتاكيد يعني لان يعني التطور اللافت كان
مؤخرا هو صواريخ المحموله على الكتف والتي
شهدنا كفاله القسام التي تابعه لحركه
الحماس قامت باطلاق هذا النوع من الصواريخ
الذي يتتبع حراريا الطائرات ولكن عاده هذه
الصواريخ تكون يعني مؤذ
يه بنسبه المروحيه ولكن بالنسبه للطائرات
الاكس 16 التي تطير على ارتفاعات شاهقه
جدا الطائرات المسيره التي تطير على
ارتفاعات شاي فهذه الصواريخ تبدو محدوده
جدا اضافه للمضادات الارضيه الكلاسيكيه
التي تستخدم رصاص من نوع 500 مليمتر وهذه
طبعا لا تؤثر بالنسبه للطائرات وبالتالي
اسرائيل هي التي تمتلك الجو وتمتلك القدره
العسكريه الكبرى في الجو وتقوم بقصف مناطق
في قطاع غزه وفق ما تشاء
ال ال ال يعني التحدي الكبير هو الموضوع
البري والذي توقفت عنه اسرائيل منذ سنوات
طوال لم تعد تدخل قواتها بشكل البريه
باتجاه قطاع غزه هي قامت حتى بجرف نحو
يعني كيلو متر كامل على حدود قطاع غزه
جعلته منطقه مكشوفه وعاده تقصف الدبابات
بعض الاماكن في قطاع غزه ولكن لا يوجد اي
توغل بري ولا تج اسرائيل بادخال قواتها
البريه الى قطاع غزه وذلك منذ سنوات يعني
طوال توقف امام الامر نعم طيب يعني عبد
الحفيظ يعني وقبل قليل مراسل العربيه
يتحدث عن عده صواريخ اطلقت منذ لحظات من
داخل قطاع غزه باتجاه المستوطنات المحاذيه
طبيعه الصواريخ التي تطلق من داخل قطاع
غزه هل هي مشابهه لصواريخ التي اطلقت صباح
اليوم من جنوب لبنان باتجاه اسرائيل انا
اتحدث عن الكاتيوشا
يعني صواريخ الكاتيوش هي تصنيع تصنيع
الدولي يمكن ان اكون تصنيع روسي او تصنيع
متقن بحد كبير ولكن الصواريخ الموجوده في
قطاع غزه معظمها تصنيع محلي وان كان هناك
يعني تطور لافت فيها بعضها اصبح يصلاح الى
اكثر من 150 كلم ولكن معظم هذه الصواريخ
هي الصواريخ محدوده تصنيع محلي
تستخدم عاده طظائف الهاون التي تصل لنحو
الثلاث كيلومترات صواريخ ايضا صغيره الحجم
برؤوس متفجره لا تتعدى العشره كيلو جرامات
تصل الى نحو من 20 يعني من 10 الى 20
كيلومتر اضافه الى الصواريخ الكبيره التي
تمتلكها فقط حركتها حماس والجهاد وهذه
الصواريخ يعني عليها رؤوس متفجره تتصل الى
50 كيلو جرام ويصل مداها الى 200 كيلو
بعضها يعني اطلق باتجاه مستوطنه مدينه
ديمونا سابقا وايضا باتجاه مدينه القدس
ولكن هذه الصواريخ وادخالها في في معركه
مثل هذه يعني تطور كبير
وذلك سابقا دفع اسرائيل بقصف مباني سكنيه
وقطف ابراج وبالتالي الدخول هذا الشكل من
الصواريخ يعني ان هناك تطورا دراماتيكيا
قد حدث في سائر المواجهه حتى هذه اللحظه
كما قلت حماس والجهاد لم يشتركان بشكل
مباشر في قصف في اطلاق الصواريخ
والمقذوفات الصاروخيه فقط هي كتائب صغيره
ومجموعات صغيره التي تقوم بالرد على هذا
الهجوم الاسرائيلي نعم ابقى معنا عبد
الحفيظ جعوان مراسل العربيه ينضم الينا من
قطاع غزه محمد عوض الصحفي اهلا وسهلا بك
الى هذه التغطيه المفتوحه هل لديك اي
معلومات جديده من حيث انت من قطاع غزه
شهدنا قبل دقيقتين من الان اطلاق عدد من
المقذوفات الصاروخيه تجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه المنتخبه للمناطق الشماليه
لاستطاع غزه تزعمنا مع هذه الصواريخ تفعيل
طائرات على انذار دون تفعيل منظومه القبه
الحديديه هذه الصواريخ التي ما زالت تنطلق
من قطاع غزالات بعد هدول لنصف ساعه من
الغارات الاسرائيليه التي تركزت على مواقع
تدفع للفصاله الفلسطينيه في شمال قطاع غزه
حيث تقوم الفصاله الفلسطينيه بين الاخره
باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ اتجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه الملاصقه للقطاع غزه يبدو
اننا امام دوله تصعيد قد تمتد بساعات لكن
اود الاشاره هنا لان مصدر امني مصري
تحدثنا معه قبل قليل قال بان جهود مصريه
وامم متحده تدخل على خط الوساطه بشكل قوي
وثقيل من اجل وقف التصعيد في قطاع غزه مع
استهداف اسرائيل لمواقع للفصل الفلسطينيه
ومواقع لحماس اضافه الى استهداف لاراضي
زراعيه الى الشرقة من مدينه غزه مما ادى
الى انهيار جزئي في احد منازل المواطنين
في حي الشجاعيه الى الشرق من مدينه غزه
هذا المنزل الذي تعرض الى الانهيار الجزئي
نتيجه كثافه الغارات التي لحقت في الارض
الزراعيه المجاوره لهذا المنزل الدفاع
المدني اجلى سكان هذا المنزل واخلى سكان
هذا المنزل الى منطقه امنه مع استمرار
الغارات الاسرائيليه من قبل المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه التي ما زالت تحلق في الاجواء
اجواء قطاع غزه
يبقى نتحدث الان نسمع انفجارات وهي ناتجه
عن اطلاق مغطاه صاروخيه تجاه البلدات
الايطاليه الملاصقه لقطاعي غزه على الارض
وتحدثنا حاله الترقب والتحوف تزداد شيئا
فشيئا خاصه مع يعني اتساع القصف
الاسرائيليه على مواقع تدفع للفصال
الفلسطينيه من جانب ثم استهداف لاراضي
جماعيه من جانب اخر ومن ثم رد الفصاله
الفلسطينيه بالصواريخ اتجاه البلدات
المناطق لقطع غزه
الغريب في هذه المرهم بان الفصاله
الفلسطينيه استخدمت استراتيجيه جديده وهي
اطلاق المضادات المتطوره تجاه طائرات
الاسرائيليه التي ما زالت تحلق وتطلق
بالونات حراريه تخوفا من اصابتها من تلك
النعم دفاعات نستطيع القول عنها انها
متوسطه او بدائيه الا ان الجيش يتخوف من
اصابه المقاتلات ويطلق البالونات خاصه وان
هذه المضادات التي يتم اطلاقها هي مضادات
حراريه تلاحق الحراره في السماء كما
شاهدنا قبل قليل وما اطلاق هذه المضادات
يتم تفعيل ايضا فقرات على الارض في
المستوطنات المرافقه لقطاع غزه وهنا
التخوف يزداد شيئا فشيئا يزداد يعني كل
لحظه
استمرار هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي على
اقتطاع غزه ايضا مصادر محليه لم تؤكدها
وزاره الصحه تقول بان الاسعافات توجهت الى
الشرق من مدينه غزه
للبحث عن مصابين في الاماكن المستهدفه
يعني انت تعرف الجميع يعلم بان التصيد بدا
في ساعات الليل وان هناك صعوبه في الوصول
الى المناطق القسط خاصه
مناطق هامشيه وقريبه من الحدود يبعد عنها
السكان
والمواطنين وهنا ويجد صعوبه يعني الدخول
للمكان المستهدفه خوفا من اعاده استهدافها
كما حدث في ايار عام 2021 شكرا جزيلا لك
صحفي محمد عوض من قطاع غزه نستكمل معكم
مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه المفتوحه على الهواء
مباشره لهذه الغاره على قطاع غزه التي
بدات قبل اكثر من ساعه من الان